This is 99% Invisible. I am Roman Mars. Happy New Year, beautiful nerds. It is now the impossibly futuristic-sounding 2025, and we are ringing in the new year with our 20th edition of mini-stories, featuring tales about Cold War neon signs, Japanese fire escapes, the marvels of Smello-vision,, but first we must wake up from our holiday slumber. Brace yourselves. I live in a house with seven other people. I'm going to let that sink in for a second. That is a lot of humans under one roof with a lot of different schedules, which means a lot of alarms going off anywhere from 6 a.m. to 10 a.m. There's the one that's like, but it goes for like an hour because it doesn't actually wake anyone up.
这里是《99%不可思议》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。美妙的书呆子们，新年快乐。现在是听上去充满不可能的未来感的2025年，我们将推出第20期微故事来迎接新的一年，其中的故事包括冷战时期的霓虹灯、日本的逃生梯以及气味电影的奇妙之处，但首先我们必须从节日的沉睡中醒来。做好心理准备吧。我和其他七个人住在一所房子里。我要让你们消化一下这个事实。在一个屋檐下有这么多的活人，有着各种不同的日程安排，这意味着有大量的闹铃在早上6点到10点之间的任何时间响起。其中一个闹铃听起来像是这样的，但它会响上整整一个小时，因为它实际上根本叫不醒任何人。
And then the one that really, really gets me is the duck. Now everyone has their own way of waking up. Personally, I don't really need an alarm because the fear, dread, and obligation of middle age keeps my consciousness right at the edge of alert at all times. But in my house, this morning chorus of quacks and bird songs exists because almost everyone sets their alarms early. Often, much earlier than they actually need to get up. And that's because they are building in time
然后，那个真正、真正让我抓狂的是鸭子叫。现在每个人都有自己的起床方式。就我个人而言，我其实不需要闹铃，因为中年人的恐惧、焦虑和责任感让我的意识随时保持在高度警惕的边缘。但在我家，这种由嘎嘎声和鸟鸣声组成的清晨交响乐之所以存在，是因为几乎每个人都把闹铃设得很早。通常比他们实际需要起床的时间要早得多。这是因为他们在为自己争取时间
to abuse the worst feature of their alarm. A feature so cursed and diabolical, it defeats the very purpose of any alarm. I'm talking of course about the snooze button. The snooze button is a bad solution to a conundrum that's existed for millennia. People need to sleep, but they also have things to do. In ancient Greece, Plato jolted himself out of bed with a system where a set amount of water slowly dripped into an airtight pot
去滥用闹铃最糟糕的功能。这个功能如此遭人诅咒且恶魔般地折磨人，以至于违背了任何闹铃的初衷。我当然是在说贪睡按钮。贪睡按钮是对一个存在了几千年的难题的糟糕解法。人们需要睡觉，但他们也有事情要做。在古希腊，柏拉图用一种系统让自己从睡梦中惊醒，该系统将定量的水缓慢滴入一个密封的罐子中
until the pressure was so high it would let out a piercing sound, kind of like a teapot. And during the Industrial Revolution, some towns had gigantic whistles which summoned workers to the factory. Around the same time, whole job existed for people who would go around knocking on doors and windows to wake people up. But once the alarm clock entered the household with sounds like this... and this... a backlash was inevitable. And this? A backlash was inevitable.
直到气压变得如此之高，以至于会发出刺耳的声音，有点像茶壶。在工业革命期间，一些城镇有巨大的汽笛，用来召唤工人去工厂。大约在同一时间，还存在一种专门敲击门窗叫人起床的职业。但是一旦闹钟进入千家万户，发出这样的声音……还有这样的……强烈的反弹就不可避免了。还有这个？强烈的反弹就不可避免了。
It was only a matter of time. You can sleep soundly depending upon the snooze alarm clock, the GE Telecom. It wakes you each morning and then lets you snooze. Continues to wake you just as you choose. In 1956, GE invented the world's first alarm clock with a snooze button. On top of the clock, there was a big ol' fat bar labeled snooze. That's S-N-O-O-Z. And it could not be missed. One smack of the clock and presto.
这只是时间问题。您可以安稳入睡，这全靠贪睡闹钟，GE Telecom。它每天早晨唤醒您，然后让您继续打盹。按照您的选择继续唤醒您。1956年，通用电气（GE）发明了世界上第一款带有贪睡按钮的闹钟。在闹钟顶部，有一个大而粗的条，上面标着“snooze”。也就是 S-N-O-O-Z。这个按钮极其显眼。拍一下闹钟，然后，瞧。
You just bought yourself a little more sleep. The first snooze alarm clocks were built to let you snooze for 10 to 15 minutes. But mass production required some standardization. In the 1950s, a double-digit snooze was too complicated to program into the gears of a clock at scale. So GE cut as close as they could with nine minutes. A nine-minute snooze was the choice.
你就为自己多争取了一会儿睡眠。第一代贪睡闹钟的设计是让你贪睡10到15分钟。但是大规模生产需要一定的标准化。在20世纪50年代，双位数的贪睡时间要在闹钟的齿轮上大规模编程过于复杂了。所以通用电气尽可能接近地选择了九分钟。九分钟的贪睡时间就这样被选定了。
After a millennia of trying to get ourselves out of bed at a certain time-minute snooze was the choice. After millennia of trying to get ourselves out of bed at a certain time, the snooze alarm dared to ask, do you really have to get up right now? And across the country, people more or less said, no, I don't. The clock was a major hit and as technology improved, a few competitors ended up offering alternatives to the 9 minute snooze, like the West Clocks' Drowse alarm clock. Let's see now, do I want five minutes more sleep or ten? Five. The West Clocks' alarm clock gave people the option of snoozing two different amounts of time,
在经历了数千年试图在特定时间把自己叫醒的努力之后——九分钟的贪睡时间就这样被选定了。在经历了数千年试图在特定时间把自己叫醒的努力之后，贪睡闹钟竟敢发出这样的质问：你真的非得现在就起床吗？而全国各地的人们或多或少地回答道：不，我不用。这款闹钟大获成功，随着技术的进步，一些竞争对手最终推出了替代九分钟贪睡的选择，比如韦斯特克洛克（Westclox）的“打盹”闹钟。让我想想，我是想要多睡五分钟还是十分钟？五分钟。韦斯特克洛克的闹钟让人们可以选择打盹两种不同的时间，
depending on if you hit the drowse button on the left side or the right side. Gee, I could use 10 minutes this time. Man, you just can't oversleep with this new west clock. But the drows button didn't have that sweet, sweet simplicity. Nobody wants to wake up and think about how much longer they want to sleep. People just want to sleep more. And the snooze button gave us that. Or at least that's what we thought. Despite the fact that many of our phones are still factory preset to snooze for nine minutes,
这取决于你按下的是左侧的打盹按钮还是右侧的。天哪，这次我可以来十分钟。天呐，有了这款新的韦斯特克洛克闹钟，你简直不可能睡过头。但打盹按钮并没有那种美妙绝伦的简洁性。没有人愿意醒来还要思考自己到底还想睡多久。人们只想多睡一会儿。而贪睡按钮给了我们这一点。或者至少我们是这么认为的。尽管我们的许多手机至今仍将出厂默认贪睡时间设为九分钟，
today we all know deep down that the snooze button doesn't really give us meaningful sleep. And it also doesn't let us rise. Instead, it catches us at our weakest moment when we are least capable of making decisions, when it's far easier to slap a button than to put two feet on the ground. In the end, the key to waking up might just rest in not giving yourself any other options. And the key to more sleep? Well, let me know when someone figures that out.
但今天我们内心深处都清楚，贪睡按钮并不能真正给我们带来有意义的睡眠。它也无法让我们真正清醒过来。相反，它在我们最虚弱、最没有决断力的时候抓住了我们——在这个时候，拍一下按钮远比把双脚放在地上要容易得多。归根结底，叫醒你的关键可能就在于不给自己留下任何其他选择。至于获得更多睡眠的关键？好吧，等有人研究出来的时候记得告诉我。
I'm here with 99PI editor Kelly Prime for a rare appearance on mic. So Kelly, what do you have for me today? Hi Roman. So I want you to imagine this very classic Americana neon scene. OK. So like if you imagine pictures of Broadway or vintage Las Vegas, like the street just lit up with signs sort of competing for your attention.
我今天和99PI的剪辑师凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）一起在这里，这是一次罕见的麦克风出场。所以凯利，你今天给我带来了什么？嗨，罗曼。我想让你想象一下这种非常经典的美国美式霓虹灯场景。好的。如果你想象百老汇的照片或者复古的拉斯维加斯，比如街道两旁霓虹闪烁，各种招牌仿佛在争夺你的注意力。
Can you picture that? Absolutely, I can picture that. OK, great, because that's not what I'm talking about. Okay, well, I'll erase that from my mind, okay. That's the neon that you and I are probably more familiar with, but I want to tell you a story about a different neon aesthetic.
你能想象到那个画面吗？当然，我能想象到。好的，太棒了，因为我说的不是那个。好吧，那我把它从脑子里删掉，好吧。那是你和我都可能更熟悉的霓虹灯，但我想给你讲一个关于不同霓虹灯美学的故事。
It's one that was created in the Eastern Bloc right in the middle of the Cold War. And they basically took that flashy commercial Americana style of neon and they twisted it to make this new socialist style that's completely unique to this specific place at this specific moment of history. Okay, tell me more about it. So the story starts in the mid 50s,
这种美学创造于冷战正酣时的东块阵营。他们基本上采用了那种浮夸的商业美式霓虹灯风格，并对其进行了扭曲，创造出了一种全新的社会主义风格，这种风格在这个特定历史时期的这个特定地点是完全独一无二的。好吧，跟我多讲讲。所以这个故事要从55年代中期说起，
about a decade into communism in the Eastern Bloc. At this point, people were starting to push back, to rebel. And so Soviet leaders got together and they were like, we have to work out a plan to quell some of this political unrest. And their plan was basically neon. It was called neonization was the state sponsored program. Okay I'm in tell me more. Okay neonization was a government program meant to push the idea of a brighter future. Since this is your first
当时东欧阵营的共产主义统治大约开始了十年。此时，人们开始进行反抗、抗变。因此，苏联领导人聚集在一起开会，他们商量着：我们必须制定一个计划来平息一些这种政治动乱。而他们的计划基本上就是霓虹灯。这个由国家赞助的项目被称为“霓虹化”。好吧，我入坑了，多讲点。好吧，“霓虹化”是一个政府项目，旨在推销对更光明未来的憧憬。既然这是你第一
time recording with me I will allow you that one once, but another one of those, and I'm pulling the plug. We'll see. The concept was like, okay, things are bleak, we get that, but shh, don't even worry about it. Look at these lights! So what they decided to do was change the landscape, turn things around, brighten up everything.
次和我一起录音，我破例允许你这一次，但如果再有下一次，我就要拔掉电源了。我们走着瞧吧。这个概念就像是：好吧，情况很暗淡，我们懂的，但是嘘，别担心。看看这些灯光！所以他们决定做的是改变景观，扭转局面，照亮一切。
That's David Hill, he's the director of the NEON Museum in Warsaw, which is dedicated to documenting and preserving Cold War era NEON signs. The proponents certainly argued, this will placate the public, this will bamboozle them, this will make people happy again. So rather than provide things, you know, substantive things in their lives
那是大卫·希尔（David Hill），他是华沙霓虹博物馆（NEON Museum）的馆长，该博物馆致力于记录和保护冷战时期的霓虹灯招牌。支持者们当然争辩说：这会安抚公众，这会迷惑他们，这会让人重新开心起来。所以，与其在生活中提供那些实质性的东西，你知道的，
to actually make people happy, they just decided to put lights in front of them. Exactly. Yeah, great use of resources. Okay. Okay. And so why neon specifically? Why not murals or, you know, I don't know, anything else? So the thing is that Eastern Europe actually had a history with neon and this was especially true of Warsaw. So before World War II Warsaw had been just like another modern European capital with everything that entailed including bright shiny lights. It was a shimmering pearl it was very famous for its neon signs from 1926 onwards so it had this
真正能让人们快乐的实质性东西，他们只是决定在人们眼前装上灯光。完全正确。是的，对资源的绝佳利用。好吧。好吧。那么为什么偏偏是霓虹灯呢？为什么不是壁画或者，你知道的，别的什么东西呢？事实是，东欧其实有着霓虹灯的历史，华沙尤其如此。所以在二战前，华沙就像另一个现代的欧洲首都，拥有一切与之相伴的事物，包括明亮闪耀的灯光。它是一颗闪亮的明珠，自1926年起就以其霓虹灯招牌而闻名遐迩，因此它与霓虹灯有着这种
connection to neon. But the war just basically destroyed all of them. As you can imagine, these very delicate glass tubes would not fare well in all the bombings that happened. But even though they were gone, people in Warsaw still had a really positive association with them. It really represented modernity and just generally prosperity, like before things were destroyed. So the socialist government knew that and they figured they could sort of leverage that association to foster goodwill towards the current regime. So the communist government came up with this plan to neonize the city to make everyone happy. So what's step one in this process? How do they start?
渊源。但战争基本上摧毁了所有这些霓虹灯。你可以想象，在所有的轰炸中，这些非常脆弱的玻璃管是不会有什么好下场的。但尽管它们消失了，华沙的人们对它们仍然有着非常积极的联想。它真正代表了现代性以及普遍的繁荣，就像一切被摧毁之前那样。所以社会主义政府深谙这一点，他们认为可以利用这种联想法来培养人们对当前政权的好感。因此，共产主义政府提出了这个让城市霓虹化的计划，以使每个人都开心。那么这个过程的第一步是什么？他们是如何开始的？
So one of the first things the government did was to hire some of the best artists in the nation. And some of these people actually were already talented neon artists and electricians. But many of them weren't. These were groundbreaking visual artists who were used to working on paper and canvas. They didn't necessarily
所以政府做的第一件事就是聘请国内一些最优秀的艺术家。其中一些人实际上已经是颇具才华的霓虹灯艺术家和电工。但他们中的许多人不是。这些是开创性的视觉艺术家，他们习惯于在纸张和画布上工作。他们不一定
have any pre-existing experience working with neon. So the only thing that was really limiting their imagination was the bounds of the material. They would just have a piece of cardboard and just draw lines all over it and then later realize, well, that's not really possible. We can't make that too zigzaggy or whatever the restrictions were. OK, so given that their imagination is wild and is unfettered by the constraints of neon, but there are actual physical constraints of building something in neon, what exactly did the artists end up making? I'm so glad you asked because I've been very into these since I discovered them.
有任何使用霓虹灯的既往经验。所以真正限制他们想象力的唯一因素就是材料本身的局限性。他们只会拿一块纸板，在上面画满各种线条，然后才意识到，嗯，这其实不太可行。我们不能把它设计得太曲折，或者不管有什么限制条件。好吧，既然他们的想象力狂野且不受霓虹灯约束，但用霓虹灯建造东西确实存在物理上的限制，那么艺术家们最终到底做出了什么？我很高兴你问这个，因为自从我发现它们以来，我就一直非常喜欢这些。
And I think the best way to go about it is just to show you some examples. So the first one I'm about to ask you to look at was made to decorate a flower shop. So just describe what you're seeing here. So I'm seeing very bright neon and it's a green kind of vine, lots of flowers of a couple of different colors.
我觉得最好的方法就是给你看一些例子。我要让你看的第一个例子是为一家花店装饰而制作的。所以，请描述一下你在这里看到了什么。我看到非常明亮的霓虹灯，它是一种绿色藤蔓状的东西，有很多种不同颜色的花朵。
And the flower petals, like they're not uniform. It's a green kind of vine, lots of flowers of a couple of different colors. And the flower petals, like, they're not uniform. They're like, they're kind of, they're kind of scribbly. Exactly. They're like scribbly. It looks like a sketch pad, like someone has been doodling, but on an entire building with neon. This was designed by a graphic artist, Zofia Kostetska, Malchowkowska.
而花瓣，它们不是整齐划一的。它是一种绿色的藤蔓，上面有许多不同颜色的花。花瓣看起来并不统一。它们就像是那种，那种有点杂乱无章的涂鸦。完全正确。它们就像涂鸦一样。这看起来像一本素描本，就像有人在涂鸦，但却是在整栋建筑上用霓虹灯进行涂鸦。这是由平面艺术家佐菲亚·科斯切茨卡-马尔霍夫斯卡（Zofia Kostetska Malchowkowska）设计的。
So she created this as a young graphic designer for a pavilion that sold basically carnations and roses. Nothing fancy there, except the building was covered in butterflies and flowers and grass. It was enormous. We're talking 20, 30 meters. Oh yeah, so these are big. They're huge. These are huge. Okay. So they're not like a Budweiser sign hanging in the window of a bar. They are not that. 20, 30 meters. That's the hundred feet of squiggly flowers.
所以她作为一名年轻的平面设计师，为一座主要出售康乃馨和玫瑰的展馆创造了这个设计。那里没有什么特别fancy的东西，除了整栋建筑都被蝴蝶、鲜花和青草所覆盖。它非常巨大。我们说的是20米、30米。哦，对，所以这些都很大。它们巨大无比。这些都是巨型的。好吧。所以它们不是那种挂在酒吧窗户上的百威啤酒招牌。它们可不是那种。20、30米。那是长达一百英尺的扭曲花朵。
That's amazing. It's crazy. Yeah. Okay. So the next one I want to show you is actually, the scale is not the same, but it is one of my favorites. It's a pink mermaid and she's holding up a sword and shield, which is like the mermaid with the sword and shield is the symbol of the city of Warsaw.
这太棒了。这太疯狂了。是的。好吧。所以我接下来要给你们看的这个，其实它的规模不一样，但它是我最喜欢的作品之一。这是一只粉红色的美人鱼，她高举着宝剑和盾牌，这就好比带着宝剑和盾牌的美人鱼是华沙市的象征。
And she's hovering over an open book. Wherever you saw this beautiful pink mermaid sitting on an open book, she would denote your public library. So Biblioteca Publicina. Wonderful. So you would see the symbol all over the place in Warsaw. That's so cool. This thing is beautiful.
她盘旋在一本打开的书上方。无论你在哪里看到这只美丽的粉红色美人鱼坐在打开的书上，它就代表着你的公共图书馆。也就是 Publicina 图书馆。太棒了。所以你在华沙到处都能看到这个符号。太酷了。这个东西太漂亮了。
It's hard to imagine neon over municipal buildings. Exactly. I was in, I was in Socrates, New York, like literally yesterday, and there was a pink neon framing of this old industrial bridge. And I was just like mesmerized by that thing. And just that sort of juxtaposition of neon and just kind of pretty mundane municipal design and decay was lovely.
很难想象市政建筑上会有霓虹灯。确实。我甚至就在昨天还在纽约苏格拉底，那里有一个旧工业桥梁的粉红色霓虹灯边框。我当时就被那东西迷住了。霓虹灯与那种相当平淡的市政设计和衰败之间的这种并置非常可爱。
It was a revelation to me, I loved it. Yeah, I want more of that. And that was very much the thing here, like very much the thing. So by the late 60s, Warsaw had hundreds of thousands of these signs across the city. But what's really striking to me is the fact that all of these neon signs had this cohesiveness to them. If you cast your mind to that, again, American scene of a street covered in neon, what you're going to see is a big sort of mishmash of color.
这对我来说是个启示，我太喜欢了。是的，我想要更多这样的东西。这在这里确实是非常普遍的现象，非常普遍。所以在60年代末，华沙全市有成千上万个这样的招牌。但真正让我震惊的是，所有这些霓虹灯招牌都具有这种凝聚力。如果你回想一下美国街道被霓虹灯覆盖的那个场景，你会看到各种颜色的大杂烩。
But in Poland, that was not at all the case. We're looking at something as a very well thought out coherent project and I think that delivered a slightly different aesthetic, a different feeling. As if, my god, the city is a city of neon, it's a city of light and it all seems to work together. It all seems to be harmonious. And a big reason for that is the fact that this neonization process was run by the state. There was actually a central body that commissioned and signed off on every single sign. You'd think they'd have better things to do. Yeah, no, I guess not.
但在波兰，情况完全不是这样。我们看到的是一个经过深思熟虑且连贯的项目，我认为这呈现了一种略微不同的美学、不同的感觉。就好像，天哪，这座城市是一座霓虹之城，是一座光之城，而且这一切似乎都融为一体。这一切似乎都和谐一致。而其中一个很大的原因就是，这个霓虹化过程是由国家主导的。实际上有一个中央机构负责委托并审批每一个招牌。你可能会觉得他们有更重要的事情要做。是的，不，我想并没有。
And all these signs were specifically designed to complement each other, so no one piece was approved unless it fit into the style of the whole. You can see how seriously the authorities took this in that eventually the chief city architect's title was abolished and it became the chief city graphic designer. So there was less importance on architecture and more placed on neonization and the urban aesthetic, the design. So after all this neonization, Warsaw is covered in neon. But did their ultimate goal actually bear fruit? I mean, were people actually happier?
而且所有这些招牌都是经过专门设计以彼此互补的，所以如果没有融入整体风格，任何一个作品都不会被批准。你可以看出当局对这件事是多么认真，因为最终首席城市建筑师的头衔被废除了，取而代之的是首席城市平面设计师。因此，建筑学的重要性降低了，而霓虹化以及城市美学、设计则受到了更多的重视。所以在经历了所有这些霓虹化之后，华沙到处都是霓虹灯。但是他们的最终目标真的结出硕果了吗？我的意思是，人们真的更快乐了吗？
Did they convince the people of Poland that everything was okay? Well, first of all, it's hard to say how people in Poland felt about neonization in general. Certainly the signs were really beautiful and it's easy to appreciate their beauty, but it's also safe to say that this tricked exactly no one into thinking that, you know, life under communism was really great.
他们说服了波兰人民一切都好吗？嗯，首先，很难说波兰人对整体的霓虹化作何感想。当然，这些招牌确实非常漂亮，人们也很容易欣赏它们的美丽，但也可以肯定地说，这绝对没有蒙骗任何人去相信，你知道的，共产主义下的生活真的很美好。
By the early 80s, things had in fact gotten so bad that the socialist government instituted martial law. And that really took a toll on Warsaw's neon. These neon signs were switched off. The authorities said, well, you don't need them. You know, you're under house arrest. Why would you want to go out in the evening? So they were basically switched off and they were really the first rather obvious victims of this new political revolution that brought in democracy.
到80年代初，情况实际上已经变得如此糟糕，以至于社会主义政府实行了戒严。这确实给华沙的霓虹灯带来了沉重的打击。这些霓虹灯招牌被关闭了。当局说，嗯，你们不需要它们。你知道的，你们都在软禁中。你为什么还要在晚上出门？所以它们基本上被关闭了，它们确实成了这场带来民主的新政治革命的第一个相当显而易见的牺牲品。
And what happened next, you probably know, communism in the Eastern Bloc didn't last. In 1989, Poland's communist state was officially replaced by a new democratic government. And when that happened, that was really the end for Warsaw's neons. The new democratic Polish government looked at the symbols from this period of occupation as they saw it, and neon was the obvious target. And so they set about destroying as many neon signs as they could in what they called the
接下来发生了什么，你大概也知道，东欧阵营的共产主义并没有持续下去。1989年，波兰的共产主义国家正式被一个新的民主政府所取代。而当这一切发生时，华沙的霓虹灯也就真正走到了尽头。新的民主波兰政府将这一占领时期的象征视为他们眼中的耻辱，而霓虹灯则是显而易见的目标。于是，他们着手摧毁尽可能多的霓虹灯招牌，他们颇有些古怪地称之为
Great Recycling Scheme, rather quaintly. And we lost so many, so many neons. Wow, the Great Recycling Scheme is quite a euphemism. Yeah, people were paid to go out into the city, find the neon signs and destroy them. So are any of the original signs left up? I mean, those pictures you showed me, are those contemporary or were all the signs destroyed?
“伟大回收计划”。我们失去了如此之多、如此之多的霓虹灯。哇，“伟大回收计划”真是一个委婉的说法。是的，人们被付钱去城里寻找霓虹灯招牌并将其摧毁。那么还有任何原来的招牌留下来吗？我的意思是，你展示给我的那些照片，它们是当代的，还是所有的招牌都被摧毁了？
So those pictures I showed you are contemporary. Those are photos of some of the few signs that did manage to survive all this time. But most of Warsaw's neons were either broken or taken down. And eventually the remnants of neonization just kind of faded into the backdrop of the city rather than being what they once were, which is, you know, a focal point of it. But I will say that in the last 20 or so years, there has been renewed interest among the residents of Warsaw in those signs and their history.
所以，我给你们看的那些照片是当代的。那些是少数几块历经沧桑幸存下来的霓虹灯招牌的照片。但华沙的大多数霓虹灯要么被砸碎，要么被拆除了。最终，霓虹化残存的痕迹只是逐渐淡入了城市的背景中，而不再像以前那样成为城市的焦点。但我得说，在过去的大约20年里，华沙居民对这些招牌及其历史重新燃起了兴趣。
I do have some really good news and that is that Warsaw is undergoing a bit of a renaissance. Neonization has returned. Today people come from around the world to see what's left of Warsaw's neons. And David says that there are now new neon signs all over Warsaw. And some of them are directly referencing the work of Poland's great neon artists. You see these fantastic places that young people hang out. And you look and you think, I've seen that before. That's a neon design by Jan Młodzki,
我确实有一个非常好的消息，那就是华沙正在经历某种复兴。霓虹化已经回归。今天，人们从世界各地赶来参观华沙残留的霓虹灯。大卫说，现在华沙到处都有新的霓虹灯招牌。其中一些直接借鉴了波兰伟大霓虹艺术家的作品。你会看到这些年轻人经常光顾的奇妙场所。你看一眼就会想：我以前见过这个。那是扬·姆沃德茨基（Jan Młodzki）设计的霓虹灯，
this famous neonizer and Polish poster artist. And there it is on the streets of Warsaw, reinvented for the modern age, reinvented for the young people. Well, thank you, Kelly. Thanks, Roman. And if you'd like to see some examples of these Polish neon signs, we'll have some
这位著名的霓虹灯设计师和波兰海报艺术家。它就这样出现在华沙的街头，为现代重新焕发生机，为年轻人重新焕发生机。好的，谢谢你，凯利。谢谢你，罗曼。如果你想看一些这些波兰霓虹灯招牌的例子，我们会在网站上放一些
pictures on the website. Coming up, our digital director Kurt Kohlstedt figures out how to escape from a burning building in Japan. News you can use. And our pal Gillian Jacobs talks to us about movies you can smell. That's after the break. We are back with digital director, Kurt Kohlstedt. Kurt, what do you have for us? Yeah, so I wanted to tell you about this small design element
图片。接下来，我们的数字总监库尔特·科尔施泰特（Kurt Kohlstedt）将为我们讲解如何从日本着火的建筑中逃生。这是对你有用的新闻。我们的老朋友吉莉安·雅各布斯（Gillian Jacobs）将跟我们聊聊可以闻到气味的电影。中场休息后马上回来。我们和数字总监库尔特·科尔施泰特回来了。库尔特，你给我们带来了什么？是的，所以我想跟你聊聊这个小型设计元素，
that I first encountered in Tokyo. I was walking around and I started to notice these red stickers that were shaped like perfect equilateral triangles and stuck to the windows of a bunch of different buildings. Here's a picture to show you what I'm talking about. Okay, so let's see. Yes, it's a red triangle, the tip pointing down, and it's centered right in the middle
我最初是在东京遇到它的。我四处走动，开始注意到这些形状像完美等边三角形的红色贴纸，它们贴在许多不同建筑物的窗户上。这里有一张照片可以向你展示我所说的是什么。好的，让我看看。是的，这是一个红色的三角形，尖端朝下，它正居中在
of every window that I see. Like it doesn't seem accidental or put on by the people, you know, haphazardly on the inside. Right, there's a certain consistency to it. There's like one upside down red triangle every couple of windows. And then, you know, once I noticed them, I started to see these stickers everywhere,
我看到的每一个窗户的中间。它看起来并不像是偶然的，也不是人们在里面随随便便贴上去的。没错，它有一种固定的规律性。每隔几个窗户就会有一个倒置的红色三角形。然后呢，一旦我注意到它们，我就开始到处看到这些贴纸，
not just in Tokyo, but then later in Osaka, in Kobe, in Kyoto. You know, now that I've seen these pictures, I have to admit, I didn't see these when I was in Japan. So what's up with all these stickers? So they're called Fire Department Access stickers. And you shouldn't feel too bad about missing them. It really helped that I had one smack dad in the middle of my first hotel room window in Tokyo.
不仅在东京，后来还在大阪、神户、京都看到过。你知道，既然我看到了这些照片，我不得不承认，我在日本的时候并没有看到这些。所以这些贴纸到底是干什么的？它们被称为“消防部门通道贴纸”。你没注意到它们也不用太自责。其实我在东京住的第一家酒店的窗户正中央就贴着一个，这确实帮了大忙。
So I did some research and I found out that in an emergency, the red triangles indicate to firefighters where to lean their ladders. And then on the inside, they have explanatory text that tells people in the building where they should go and expect to find rescue. Do the triangles indicate that the windows are somehow different or that they're just the gathering point of a rescuer meeting rescuee? Well, yeah, so I looked into that and some of what I read indicated that these windows could be opened more easily, like either by firefighters from the outside or people from the inside. And one account indicated that they might be built out of more breakable glass too, so that like you can shatter them in an emergency.
所以我做了一些研究，我发现如果在紧急情况下，这些红色三角形会向消防员指示应该把梯子靠在哪里。然后在内部，它们有说明性的文字，告诉大楼里的人他们应该去哪里以及预期在哪里找到救援。这些三角形是表明窗户有什么不同，还是它们只是救援人员与被救援人员碰头的集合点？嗯，是的，所以我研究了一下，我读到的一些内容表明，这些窗户可以更容易地打开，比如可以由外部的消防员打开，也可以由内部的人打开。还有一个说法表明它们可能是用更容易破碎的玻璃建造的，这样你就可以在紧急情况下把它们砸碎。
And then I noticed under my window in my hotel room that there was this metal stick which clearly wasn't there to open the window. And I got to wondering like, is that so that I can smash the window? And I confess I did not test the theory. And so I cannot confirm if that's why the stick was there. Well, regardless of whether these arrows are indicators of any structural or physical difference about these windows, this is a place where you can go to get out of the building in an emergency. Yeah, exactly. It's a meeting point.
然后我注意到我酒店房间的窗户下面有一根金属棒，这显然不是用来开窗的。我开始琢磨：那是为了让我砸碎窗户用的吗？我承认我并没有测试这个理论。因此我无法确认这就是那根棒子在那里的原因。好吧，不管这些箭头是否表明这些窗户在结构或物理上有任何不同，这里都是你在紧急情况下可以前往以逃离大楼的地方。是的，完全正确。这是一个汇合点。
I guess I'm just kind of surprised that I missed these stickers. Like, are they only on certain kinds of buildings, or are they just all kind of high up? Well, yeah, you're on the right track there. Height is the key determinant, because if you think about it, like smaller buildings, including houses that only have a story or two, obviously wouldn't need these at all. And on taller buildings, they'd only be needed within a certain height range because of course, if a window is too high to be reached by a firefighter ladder, it would be dark to encourage people to congregate there, frankly.
我只是有点惊讶我竟然漏掉了这些贴纸。比如，它们只出现在某些类型的建筑物上，还是它们都处于比较高的位置？嗯，是的，你的方向是对的。高度是决定性的关键因素，因为如果你想想看，较小的建筑物，包括只有一两层楼的房屋，显然根本不需要这些。而在较高的建筑物上，它们也仅在一定高度范围内需要，因为当然了，如果窗户太高，消防员的梯子够不到，坦白说，贴在那里也就毫无意义了。
I see. There's only a narrow band where these are functional. They have to be high enough that you wouldn't just get out by yourself on the first floor or second floor, but low enough that it'd be possible for a firefighter's ladder to reach you. Yeah, exactly. And from the regulation accounts that I was reading, of course, in translation and secondary sources, it appears that it's about 100 feet where these things cap out. Okay. So that's the reason why I missed them.
我明白了。只有在一个狭窄的区间内这些才是起作用的。它们必须足够高，以至于你不能只靠自己从一楼或二楼逃生，但又必须足够低，以至于消防员的梯子有可能能够够到你。是的，完全正确。根据我阅读的规章制度记录，当然是通过翻译和二手资料，似乎这些东西的上限大约是100英尺。好的。这就是为什么我没有注意到它们的原因。
Because it's within 20 feet to 100 feet. Yeah, totally. And they're really, I mean, quite small. So unless you're looking for them, they're easy to miss too, right? And you know, this actually all kind of led me back to this little journey of discovery that I took when we first met, which was over a decade ago
因为它们在20英尺到100英尺之间。对，完全是这样。而且它们真的，我是说，相当小。所以除非你在寻找它们，否则也很容易错过，对吧？你知道的，这实际上让我回溯到了我们刚见面时的一次小小的发现之旅，那已经
now, if you can believe it. I mean, I can believe it. It's been a while. I can't imagine the show before you. So it's one of those things. So what did it remind you of though? Well, we had this lunch together in Oakland and and we were walking around, and you pointed out this little black box next to a building entrance, and then another and another and so on. And they all had these little red reflective stripes. And those are, of course, Knox boxes, which you've talked about a couple of times.
是十多年前的事了，如果你敢相信的话。我的意思是，我敢相信。已经过去一段时间了。我无法想象没有你的节目会是什么样。所以就是这么回事。不过这让你想起了什么？好吧，我们在奥克兰一起吃了午餐，当时我们正在散步，你指出了建筑入口旁边的一个小黑盒，然后又是一个，再一个，以此类推。它们都有这些小小的红色反光条。而这些，当然就是“诺克斯箱”（Knox boxes），你已经谈到过好几次了。
And if you don't remember those episodes or didn't read the book that Kurt and I co-authored, those contain a set of keys for the building building and then all those Knox boxes are held by firefighters. So if there is a crisis, they can open up this box, therefore have all the keys to the building and then get in and out more easily. Yeah, exactly. And so you were there for me 10 years ago, drawing my attention to something and then
如果你不记得那些分集，或者没有读过我和库尔特合著的那本书，那些箱子里装着大楼的一套钥匙，而所有这些诺克斯箱都由消防员保管。因此，如果发生危机，他们可以打开这个箱子，从而获得大楼的所有钥匙，然后更轻松地进出。对，完全正确。所以你10年前就在那里帮助我，把我的注意力吸引到某些事物上，然后
filling in the backstory. So this is me returning the favor. Well, that was fun, Kurt. Thank you so much. Yeah, thank you, Roman. Up next is actor and frequent 9iMPI contributor, Gillian Jacobs. Hey, Gillian, welcome back.
补充背景故事。所以这是我投桃报李。嗯，那很有趣，库尔特。非常感谢。是的，谢谢你，罗曼。接下来是演员兼9PI的常驻嘉宾吉莉安·雅各布斯。嗨，吉莉安，欢迎回来。
Thanks so much for having me, Roman. It's great to have you back. So what do you have for us today? Well, I wanted to talk about a very particular and peculiar movie. Roman, have you ever seen the film, Scent of Mystery? No, but I like the way you say, Scent of Mystery. I feel like it can only be said like that.
非常感谢邀请我来，罗曼。很高兴你能回来。所以你今天给我们带来了什么？嗯，我想聊一部非常特别且奇特的电影。罗曼，你看过《神秘的气味》（Scent of Mystery）这部电影吗？没有，但我喜欢你叫它《神秘的气味》时的语气。我觉得它只能被那样称呼。
So tell me more about Scent of Mystery. Well, no judgment for never having heard of it because it's a very obscure movie from 1960. But as you may be able to deduce, it is a mystery film about a mysterious woman in danger. It has Peter Laurie, wine barrels, Spain, bad Spanish. Señor, por favor, young lady, in a big hat, muchos sombreros, uh, dandy.
所以多跟我讲讲《神秘的气味》。嗯，对于没听说过这部电影的人，我绝对不作评判，因为它是一部1960年非常冷门的小众电影。但正如你大概能推断出的那样，这是一部关于一个陷入危险的神秘女性的悬疑电影。里面有彼得·洛瑞（Peter Laurie）、酒桶、西班牙、糟糕的西班牙语。“先生，拜托，年轻女士，戴着大礼帽，许多帽子，呃，花花公子。”
Uh, the reason I want to talk to you about it today is because my friend Joan saw it when it first came out in theaters and is still talking about it because of something unique about scent of mystery. So what do you remember about that day and about the movie? Okay, so much about the movie. I think we got popcorn because, you know, this was a big event for us to go downtown. So back in 1960, when Scent of Mystery first premiered, Joan was a kid living in Chicago, and it turns out she and her siblings were part of a very small group of moviegoers who got to see it exhibited in its full intended experience, which was demonstrated by this one scene in particular. So all of a sudden, as I'm sitting there, this, the main character, some chase thing is going on and the main character all of a sudden goes into a flower market and this gush of sweet smell comes in our face and neither of us can breathe and of
呃，我今天想和你聊聊它的原因是因为我的朋友琼在它刚上映时在电影院看过，直到现在还在谈论它，原因正是关于《神秘的气味》的一个独一无二的特点。那么你对那天以及这部电影有什么记忆？好吧，关于电影有很多记忆。我想我们买了爆米花，因为，你知道的，对我们来说去市中心是一件大事。所以在1960年，《神秘的气味》首次上映时，琼还是一个住在芝加哥的孩子，事实证明她和她的兄弟姐妹是一小群幸运的电影观众之一，得以观看它以其原本预期的完整体验进行展映，这由其中一个特定场景得到了完美的展示。所以突然之间，当我坐在那里的时候，这个，主角，某个追逐戏正在进行，主角突然走进了一个花市，一股甜蜜的气味冲向我们的脸，我们俩都喘不过气来，当然
course I had to rush over and get away from the smell. A gush of sweet smell. I'm not sure what word in that phrase I find the most objectionable. What kind of smell are we talking about here? So as it turns out, what Joan was experiencing in that movie theater was smell-o-vision. Roman, what do you know about smell-o-vision? I mean, not much other than the name. I'm sure it has something to do with the technology that allows you to smell a movie as you're
我不得不赶紧跑过去离那个气味远点。一股甜蜜的气味。我不确定这句话里哪个词让我觉得最反感。我们在这里谈论的是哪种气味？事实证明，琼在那个电影院里体验到的是“气味电影”（Smell-O-Vision）。罗曼，你对气味电影了解多少？我的意思是，除了名字之外了解不多。我确信它与某种技术有关，这种技术能让你在观看电影时
watching it. But I didn't think there was much more to it than that. Oh, Roman, buckle up. It was the brainchild of American film producer Mike Todd Jr. And Mike Todd Jr. was the son of, you guessed it, Mike Todd Sr., who was a hugely successful theatrical impresario and husband of Elizabeth Taylor. Oh, okay. Wow.
闻到电影里的气味。但我没想到除了这个之外还有更多内容。哦，罗曼，系好安全带。这是美国电影制片人迈克·托德二世（Mike Todd Jr.）的脑洞产物。而迈克·托德二世是——你猜对了——迈克·托德一世的儿子，后者是一位极其成功的戏剧 impresario（经纪人/制作人）兼伊丽莎白·泰勒的丈夫。哦，好吧。哇。
So Mike Todd Sr. was this big ideas guy who loved gimmicks and doing things on a grand scale like his hit Oscar-winning film Around the World in 80 Days. It was chock-full of cameos and stars and as you could guess, shot around the world. But then Mike Todd Sr. tragically died in a plane crash in 1958, leaving his son, Mike Jr. to run his production company when he was only 28 years old. And Mike Todd Jr. wanted to continue his father's legacy of spectacle. And in this moment of uncertainty, he remembered this technology that his father was intrigued by and had actually considered implementing in Around the World in 80 Days, this thing called SmellBrain.
所以迈克·托德一世是个满脑子大想法的人，他喜欢各种噱头，喜欢搞大场面，比如他那部荣获奥斯卡奖的热门电影《环游世界八十天》（Around the World in 80 Days）。里面塞满了客串明星，正如你所能猜到的那样，是在世界各地取景拍摄的。但随后迈克·托德一世于1958年在一次飞机失事中不幸身亡，留下他的儿子迈克·托德二世在年仅28岁时接管他的制作公司。而迈克·托德二世想要延续他父亲追求奇观的传统。在这个充满不确定性的时刻，他想起了这项曾让他父亲着迷、并实际考虑在《环游世界八十天》中应用的技术，一个叫做“气味大脑”（SmellBrain）的东西。
That needs some work. I know. So, smell brain was this device invented by an Austrian osmologist named Hans Lobb, and it was essentially a conveyor belt full of vials containing smell cues. And when prompted, the smell brain would pump the scent cue to each seat in the theater individually using a series of tubes. So it was like this synced smell experience matching what was on the screen. Exactly. Mike Todd Jr. remembered the smell brain and lob and thought, okay, I'm going to invest all of my money and the resources from my dad's production company because what moviegoers really want is to smell the movies. And this is with no market testing to support it, just the firm belief people would be so
这名字需要润色一下。我知道。所以，气味大脑是由一位名叫汉斯·洛布（Hans Lobb）的奥地利气味学家发明的设备，它本质上是一个装满了包含气味线索的小瓶的传送带。当收到提示时，气味大脑会通过一系列管道将气味线索单独泵送到剧院的每个座位上。所以这就像是一种与银幕内容同步的气味体验。完全正确。迈克·托德二世记起了气味大脑和洛布，心想：好吧，我要把我所有的钱以及我父亲制作公司的资源都投进去，因为电影观众真正想要的是去闻电影的气味。而这并没有任何市场调研来支持，仅仅是坚信人们会对
excited by the idea of sniffing stuff while watching a movie that they would rush to theaters. Well, history is made by dreamers, so go for it. Absolutely. So, Mike Todd, he's a marketing guy. So he decides to rebrand SmellBrain with a more attention-grabbing name, Smell-O-Vision. And he decided the way to debut this Smell-O-Vision technology was to produce and self-finance the first and only film made with the smell cues in mind during production, Scent of Mystery. Yeah, yeah.
看电影时闻气味的想法感到如此兴奋，以至于会蜂拥至电影院。好吧，历史是由梦想家创造的，所以放手去做吧。绝对的。所以，迈克·托德，他是个营销高手。因此他决定用一个更吸引眼球的名字来重新包装“气味大脑”——气味电影（Smell-O-Vision）。他决定推出这项气味电影技术的首发方式是制作并独立投资第一部也是唯一一部在制作过程中将气味线索考虑在内的电影，《神秘的气味》。对，对。
The title is extremely on the nose. Bah bah. Oh, sorry. I actually didn't mean that. Okay, okay. So what was different about the film Scent of Mystery from other films? Like how did it showcase the smell-o-vision technology?
这个片名真是极其直白。哈哈。哦，抱歉。我其实不是那个意思。好吧，好吧。那么电影《神秘的气味》和其他电影有什么不同呢？比如它是如何展示气味电影技术的？
So deploying scents in the movie watching experience actually goes as far back as the silent era. So maybe a theater would show a film that had a scene at the Rose Bowl, and the theater owner would put a cotton ball soaked with rose oil in front of a fan to enhance that experience for the audience. So some audiences got to experience the smell of movies before they even heard them. Yes, but in those pre-smell-o-vision experiences, the smell cues were created by the theater owners and not necessarily how the filmmaker intended the movie to be experienced.
所以在观影体验中部署气味其实可以追溯到无声电影时代。所以也许一家剧院会放映一部包含玫瑰碗场景的电影，剧院老板会把一块浸有玫瑰油的棉球放在风扇前面，以增强观众的体验。因此，一些观众甚至在听到电影声音之前就体验到了电影的气味。是的，但在那些前气味电影的体验中，气味线索是由剧院老板创造的，不一定符合电影制作人原本希望观众体验电影的方式。
Smell-o-vision and scent-of-mystery were going to be different because it was the first time the scents were going to be intentionally embedded into the production of the film and the smells would be critical to the plot. So how does a smell-driven plot even work? Okay, so like I mentioned before, there is a mysterious woman character and everyone's trying to figure out who this mysterious woman is,
气味电影和《神秘的气味》将会不同，因为这是气味第一次被刻意嵌入到电影的制作中，并且气味将对剧情至关重要。那么一个由气味驱动的剧情到底是如何运作的呢？好的，就像我之前提到的，有一个神秘的女性角色，每个人都试图弄清楚这个神秘女性是谁，
and every time you see this mysterious woman, you would smell her perfume. So the smell of the perfume was pumped into the audience, and then that smell is key to figuring out her identity. In that scene that you just heard, you would actually smell the perfume that you saw on screen. But dear listeners, you're just going to have to use your imagination. Sorry. So Mike Todd Jr. was so convinced that smell-o-vision was going to revolutionize cinema that he marketed it as a seismic advancement.
而且每当你看到这个神秘女性时，你就会闻到她的香水味。因此，香水味被泵送给观众，然后这种气味是弄清她身份的关键。在你刚听到的那个场景中，你实际上会闻到你在银幕上看到的香水味。但亲爱的听众们，你们只能靠想象力了。抱歉。所以迈克·托德二世坚信气味电影将彻底革新电影业，他将其作为一项突破性的进展进行营销。
Ads for the movie read, first they moved, then they talked, now they smell. Anyway, to really try and get butts in the seats, Mike Todd Jr. convinced his stepmother Elizabeth Taylor to appear as the aforementioned mysterious woman. And Eddie Fisher, who was Elizabeth Taylor's then husband, even contributed the title track to the film, which actually did really well. title track to the film, which actually did really well. ["A Strange Excitement in the Air"] So I'm guessing since you mentioned that The Scent of Mystery was the first and only Smell-O-Vision film, the technology behind Smell-O-Vision was not a raging success. No, not at all. Sadly, no.
电影的广告写道：首先他们会动，然后他们会说话，现在他们有气味了。无论如何，为了真正吸引观众走进影院，迈克·托德二世说服他的继母伊丽莎白·泰勒饰演前面提到的神秘女性。而埃迪·费舍尔（Eddie Fisher），也就是伊丽莎白·泰勒当时的丈夫，甚至为电影贡献了主题曲，这首歌其实反响非常好。电影的主题曲，其实反响非常好。[空气中弥漫着一种奇怪的兴奋感]所以我想既然你提到《神秘的气味》是第一部也是唯一一部气味电影，那么气味电影背后的技术并不是一个巨大的成功。不，一点也不。可悲的是，并没有。
According to audiences at the time, including my friend Joan, the technology didn't really work all that great. I think I spent the entire time going, I don't Joan, the technologies didn't really work all that great. I think I spent the entire time going, I don't smell anything, I don't smell, do I smell anything? I don't smell anything. And we thought the whole thing was kind of a bust. Some of the smells were too strong.
根据当时观众的说法，包括我的朋友琼在内，这项技术其实并没有那么好用。我想我整个过程都在说：我不知道，琼，这项技术其实并没有那么好用。我想我整个过程都在说：我什么都闻不到，我没闻到，我闻到什么了吗？我什么都闻不到。我们觉得整件事简直是个彻底的失败。有些气味太浓了。
Sometimes the smells came late. Sometimes you couldn't smell anything at all. And it cost a ton of money to install. So there were only three theaters in the United States running it in full Smell-O-Vision. So the film flopped and lost a ton of money. They later tried to recoup some of their losses by re-releasing the film under the title
有时气味来得太迟。有时你根本什么都闻不到。而且安装费用极高。因此，全美国只有三家影院在全面播放气味电影。所以这部电影票房惨败，损失了巨额资金。他们后来试图通过以《西班牙假日》（Holiday in Spain）为名重新发行这部剥离了气味电影的电影来弥补部分损失
Holiday in Spain, sans Smell-O-Vision. I tried to watch it for journalism, but it was not good. The film's scent of mystery and the name Smell-O-Vision became a joke in Hollywood. Just another goofy gimmick that didn't work. In hindsight, that seems inevitable, but I imagine in a moment that still felt sad.
。我为了做新闻尝试着看了一下，但它并不好看。《神秘的气味》这部电影和“气味电影”这个名字成了好莱坞的一个笑柄。不过又是一个不管用的蠢噱头。事后看来，这似乎是不可避免的，但我可以想象在当时那个时刻，那依然让人感到悲伤。
Everyone likes innovation, to move things forward. Absolutely, and to that point, even though Smell-O--vision died, the idea of it lived on in different forms. In 1981, John Waters directed a film called Polyester. For that, he produced scratch and sniff odorama cards. And you would get a cue on screen when to, you know, scratch your smell cue, which allowed you to do the smell-o-vision in a more low tech way. Spy Kids 4, father of children.
每个人都喜欢创新，喜欢推动事物向前发展。确实，正因如此，尽管“气味电影”（Smell-O-Vision）消亡了，但它的理念却以不同的形式延续了下来。1981年，约翰·沃特斯导演了一部名为《多脂美》的电影。为此，他制作了“刮刮闻”气味卡。当屏幕上出现提示时，你就可以去刮你的气味提示卡，这让你能够以一种技术含量较低的方式体验气味电影。《非常小特工4》，孩子的父亲。
Roman, have you watched Spy Kids 4? I don't know about 4, but I've certainly seen a couple of them. Okay, well, you missed out because Spy Kids 4 did their own scratch and sniff cards called Aromascope. And recently companies like iSmell and O-Phone have tried to introduce smells into computing mobile phones. And the latest and greatest is smells for video games. And it seems like people will never let go of the stream of smelling their media content. You know, I've been through different iterations of this where like, you know, 3D has come and gone in different waves.
罗曼，你看过《非常小特工4》吗？我不确定是不是第四部，但我确实看过其中的几部。好吧，那你可错过了，因为《非常小特工4》制作了他们自己的“刮刮闻”卡片，叫做“气味镜”（Aromascope）。最近，像 iSmell 和 O-Phone 这样的公司试图将气味引入计算和移动电话中。最新、最棒的技术是为电子游戏提供气味。看来人们永远不会放弃闻到他们媒体内容的梦想。你知道的，我经历过这个概念的不同迭代，就像3D技术曾以不同的浪潮出现又消失一样。
And I just feel like mostly it's like we've come to the idealized form, big screen, you know, a bunch of people in a dark movie theater looking at it. Like to me, that doesn't really need to be improved very much. But are you craving Warren Gillian? I'm not craving smells. I'll say that. Fair enough. Thank you so much. Thank you.
而且我只是觉得，大部分情况下，我们已经达到了它的理想形态：大屏幕，一群人在黑暗的电影院里看着它。在我看来，这其实不需要太多的改进。但是你渴望华伦·吉莉安吗？我不渴望气味。我只能这么说。说得有理。非常感谢。谢谢。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Jason DeLeon, Kelly Prime, Kurt Kohlstad, Gillian Jacobs, and Vivian Leigh. Edited by Christopher Johnson and Nina Potuck. Mixed by Martine Gonzalez. Music by Swan Real and George Langford. Cathy Chu is our executive producer, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Lashima Dawn, Jacob Medina Gleason, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks North in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California.
《99%隐形》本周由杰森·德莱昂、凯利·普莱姆、库尔特·科尔斯塔德、吉莉安·雅各布斯和薇薇安·莱伊制作。克里斯托弗·约翰逊和尼娜·波图克剪辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。音乐由斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰格福德创作。凯西·朱是我们的执行制片人，德兰尼·霍尔是我们的资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、拉希玛·唐、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森、乔·罗森伯格，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们现在是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心上城潘多拉大厦以北六个街区处。
You can now find us on the social media site. Blue sky is definitely the one to join. We are having some fun there. You can also connect with 5,000 other 99PI fans on our Discord server, where we talk about the PowerBroker, architecture, all kinds of fun stuff. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你现在可以在社交媒体网站上找到我们。Blue Sky 绝对是值得加入的一个。我们在那里玩得很开心。你还可以在我们的 Discord 服务器上与另外 5000 名 99PI 粉丝交流，我们在那里讨论《权力经纪人》、建筑以及各种有趣的事情。在 99PI.org 上有通往该频道的链接，以及 99PI 的所有往期节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。